We will now move from analyzing ideal
spectra to analyzing real spectra.
This is one of the T-Rex spectra.
And as soon as we come up with an idea
of how the peptides that generated this
spectrum look like, we can immediately
start annotating peaks in the spectrum.
For example,
this peak has a mass explained by
a prefix peptide of length 10,
while this peak
has a mass explained by a
suffix peptide of length 3.
In total, we were able to annotate
six peaks in the spectrum
using this conjecture about the peptides
that generated this spectrum, and
we say that the "Shared Peak Count" for
this spectrum and peptide is 6.
This is another idea about the peptides
that generated the same spectrum.
And in this case,
the shared peak count is higher:
we are able to annotate 10,
rather than 6 peaks in the spectrum.
Which peptide, the first one or
the second one, did Asara propose as
the peptide generating DinosaurSpectrum?
You may be surprised with this answer
because it may look like the peptide
at the bottom is definitely
a better candidate for
explaining the DinosaurSpectrum.
There's two alternatives.
Bring up the question of how should
we score an annotated spectrum?
Should we score it as a shared peak count?
Or maybe we should simply sum up
the intensities of all explained peaks.
Both options have some disadvantages.
For example,
shared peak count ignores intensity.
Sum of intensity, on the other hand,
may lead to problems when large
peaks dominate the score.
Our goal is to come up with
a probabilistic model of spectra so
that large peaks contribute to the score
but do not dominate the score.
To address this challenge,
mass spectrometrists
came up with this concept
of a "Spectral Vector,"
a transformation of a spectrum of mass m into an
m-dimensional vector: <s1, ..., si, ..., sm>.
The value si, which is known as amplitude,
approximates the likelihood
that mass i is the prefix of
an unknown peptide that
generated the spectrum.
You may be wondering how we can
transform a spectrum into a spectral
vector if we don't know the peptides
that generated this spectrum,
but this is a subject of a detour that
I will not cover in this lecture.
To elaborate on the concept
of spectral vectors,
we will first introduce a simple
notion of "Peptide Vector."
Given a peptide, we will take each amino
acid in this peptide of mass m and
represent it as an m-dimensional
binary vector with
m-1 0s in the beginning,
and and single 1 in the end.
Afterwards, we will concatenate
all vectors corresponding
to individual amino acids into
a peptide vector shown in this slide.
You can easily solve the following
problem: Given a peptide, convert it
into a peptide vector, and it is clear
that we can also solve a reverse
problem: Given a peptide vector,
transform it into a peptide.
We will now turn to a more
difficult problem of converting
a spectrum into a spectral vector.
Let's start by analyzing this peak and
converting it into an amplitude.
In this case it turns out
the amplitude for this peak is +9.
Know that it is important that +9
is not the intensity of this peak.
It is the likelihood that this
peak will be annotated by a
prefix of an unknown peptide
that generated this spectrum.
Let's press it for this peak,
it's a very short one, hardly visible.
The amplitude will be -5, and
amplitude may be negative or positive.
For this peak, it is +7 and
for this peak, it is +3.
We will combine them all into
a single spectral vector,
which is an integer-valued
vector with m coordinates.
And typically,
the larger the peak at mass i,
the larger the value of amplitude
of the spectral vector, but
the dependencies between intensities and
amplitudes are complex.